are you lost in braces questions about
the expectation of privacy during those
so called pocket dials James Stephens an
employee with the state of Georgia and
his wife we're at home one night
complaining about his boss but the boss
overheard them oh no because Stevens had
accidentally butt dialed him Steven says
the next day he was given a choice
resign or be fired so he resigned
now Stevens and his wife are suing
claiming that eavesdropping was illegal
mark Strassmann is in Atlanta with this
story mark good morning this is a good
one good morning it is a good one the
butt dial or pocket dial we've all sent
them we've all received them here's what
you may not know if you get one and you
realize that you're eavesdropping on a
private conversation you may have a
legal obligation to hang up even what
you're listening to is something juicy
about you he had a tendency to call me
after-hours Pavia
James Stevens his boss Michael Cohen
called him at home late one night when
the call ended Gina Stevens had
something to say not the first time it
had happened and so I was a little
irritated that we had had that intrusion
you presented it yes sir
Cowan overheard them talking for about
12 minutes that's how long it took James
Stevens to realize he had pocket-dialed
his boss I did hang it up immediately
and what did you say to the next day
Stevens who worked for the state of
Georgia says he was forced to resign his
six-figure job gave me the option of
resigning our being fired the Stevens
sued Cohen personally claiming he had
invaded their right to privacy with
voyeuristic eavesdropping that was
felonious conduct lawyer David golden
shoe represents the Stevens he argues
their conversation was private
Cohen knew it and he was legally
obligated to hang up you may not use an
electronic device to listen into a
conversation you know to be a private
conversation
Cohen filed a motion to dismiss the suit
arguing and his official capacity as a
state supervisor he was listening to the
pocket-dial call of a subordinate
employee and deserves immunity we
reached out to Cohen's lawyer who said
we are unable to
comment on matters that are pending
ricky Clemen is a CBS News legal analyst
what we find here is someone who really
believes he had a reasonable expectation
of privacy and having a very very
confidential conversation with his wife
and that yet it may not be private at
all
in 2015 the Sixth Circuit US Court of
Appeals ruled on a similar case in
Kentucky it decided someone who pocket
dials another person does not have a
reasonable expectation of privacy
because they placed the call if I'm
talking to my husband just to kind of
distress and we're talking to one
another in your own home in my own home
then no I don't think that that should
lead to termination remember next step
state judge has to decide whether Cohen
was acting in his official capacity as a
state supervisor and therefore deserves
immunity but if the judge rules this is
a case of one private person
eavesdropping on another this case moves
forward John Mark thanks very much I
don't know anybody that would not have
listened to that conversation I've
listened to conversations even if
they're not about me just out of
curiosity yes just if it accidentally
happened just because I'm thinking what
are they talking about over there I know
I would really the things you talked
about with close friends ears yes you
don't want other people that yeah I
should would you guys have hung up
that's what I'd like to know we got a we
got to leave that in abeyance Gail